you made this whole point about our guys  that you've got that are friends that in  your friend zone yeah and they don't  move out their friend zone because  they're your friends they would never  step out but this whole argument started  because you said  when you decide to have a kid you'll  just pick one at the friend zone so you  contradict yourself straight away okay  I'll explain myself let's go again so  let me explain your contradiction go  explain the contradiction what I want my  ideal situation is to have a man that I  meet with respect each other to be gone  really well we have a lot for one of  them is there anyone in your friend zone  now no no no no no this is gonna be  somebody new because obviously if that  was the case I would have done it by now  so anyway and actually fall in love with  them  that's more unrealistic though in your  dreams  asked me to explain it every time I say  something you just interrupt that's why  you don't get the point so